welcome to the week in 60 minutes from
spectator tv we've got another great
show for you tonight
uh we're going to be joined we hope by
professor david nabarro he's special
envoy on covert 19 for the world
health organization the who he reports
directly to the director general the
spectator's home team
is also on hand to analyze the latest
local restrictions in britain
and their political ramifications and
we've got a special report from ireland
where this week
the politicians rebelled against the
scientific advice
excuse me and further afield of course
we go to the states
uh and give you the reaction to last
night's vice
presidential debate and we as always
we'll take your questions you can email
them at spectator
tv that's all one word spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
now if you like what we're doing here
and why wouldn't you after all
it's free you can subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
for free as well if you're already
watching on youtube just tap
the spectator tv logo at the bottom
right hand corner of your screen
you'll then receive a notification
whenever a new episode is aired
we'd like to give a very special thanks
to charles stanley for supporting this
episode
and charlotte stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
and one of the oldest firms on the
london
stock exchange they'll look after your
money
now ireland i mentioned that at the top
of
the show throughout the pandemic
and across the world politicians have
paraded their top
scientists some may say even hidden
behind them to justify
their covert responses always claiming
to be following the signs but something
very different happened this week
when irish scientific advisors told the
dublin government
they needed to return to a full lockdown
the politicians they said no the tea
shop
the prime minister martin rejected the
recommendation to revert to level five
that's the maximum
alert level in ireland while deputy
prime minister varadka
said that the scientific advice had
been thought through his exact words so
what's going on
i'm joined now by pat alihi he's the
political editor of the
irish times pat did anybody see this
coming it sounds quite dramatic
well it was pretty dramatic last weekend
uh andrew and if we were all taken by
surprise
by the sudden departure from the public
health service at the public
government's public health experts with
their recommendation
on sunday that we should go to more or
less
back to the lockdown we saw
for three months in the spring and early
summer but if we were surprised
by that of the country was surprised the
government was surprised by it as well
only a few days previous to that
the public health experts who meet
routinely and make a report to
government
had told the government that they didn't
see any need to raise the
level of restrictions at that point that
was on thursday
and on sunday they held a special
meeting albeit against the
background of cases which have been
rising
pretty quickly uh over the last two
weeks
or so and uh they made this shock
recommendation that we
we should return to lockdown uh more or
less
uh immediately government rejected that
and not alone did they reject it but
they were highly critical
both privately perhaps you might expect
that but also
publicly of the way that the public
health experts
arrived at their advice and more or less
landed it on the government on sunday
without warning there's an aspect of
uh of of this that i think is worth just
bringing to your attention for
a moment and that's that the head of the
government's
body of public health experts a guy
called dr tony houlihan
who was very much the face of this
strong
medical and scientific advice to lock
down during the first
phase in the spring he's been off on
compassionate family leave
for the last number of months but on
sunday he returned actually a day
earlier than he was supposed to return
he arrived he was due back at his desk
on monday he arrived on sunday called a
meeting
and issued the uh the lockdown
recommendations
and this was viewed in government by
many people and
a number of ministers said it to me as
sort of
a power play if you like a signal that
look
dr tony is back he's taking control
we have to go back to lockdown but the
government took um
as you say a very different view has the
government
made clear why it doesn't agree with the
scientific advice it's had
it had two problems i suppose with the
way
uh with with the actions of the public
health
experts on sunday the first was the
manner in which they did it a
very quick meeting uh to make the
recommendations without going through
the sort of normal channels that you
might expect both formally
and informally with uh with the
government they simply landed
the uh the recommendation to go back to
lockdown
on the government on sunday night not
entirely
uh without warning there had been some
back channeling but nothing uh to the
extent that
gave the government what they felt was
adequate warning so
governments were annoyed at at the
procedure the process
that they followed but they also took
the view on the substance
of the public health experts advice
that while they didn't dispute the
grounds on which
they were making the advice it's very
clear to everybody that numbers have
been going up alarmingly
over the last couple of weeks their view
was that they had to make
a decision which took into other factors
and the minister for finance
for instance was very strong both in
public and
in private that to take the advice of
the public experts and go straight
to a lockdown would cost hundreds of
thousands of jobs
over the coming week over the coming
weeks jobs that would not come back
and in his view and in the view of most
of his fellow ministers
uh they needed to they needed to see if
a less
strict lockdown over the coming weeks
would
uh would work so their view was that
they had to take into
uh they had to take into consideration
other elements not just
economic but other social elements as
well
as well as just the public health advice
in making their decision wouldn't one of
the things that
influenced the politicians be though as
you say the number of cases in ireland
is rising
though still only about 490 on a daily
uh basis deaths
are two the seven day moving average of
deaths are two and seven days ago
the seven day moving energy of deaths
were two i mean
maybe a lot of people would think well
if that's the fatality rate
then the government was maybe right not
to follow
not to lock down the economy on the
basis of two
deaths with no sign yet that that death
rate is rising
yeah and this is one of the questions i
think that has to be answered at the
moment you're right about the
the the death rate the figures for today
is there there's only 157 people
in hospital with this illness today
there's only 27 people across the whole
uh the whole of the republic in
intensive care units now of course the
uh worry from public uh public health
doctors
is that you know the the numbers
infected and the numbers that need to be
admitted to hospital and and and
thereafter into icu
units uh increases very quickly you get
this exponential rise in case and
all of a sudden within a relatively
short period of time the public health
system
is uh is overwhelmed but there's no
sense of that happening at the moment so
while
cases have certainly been increasing
uh very significantly over the last two
two and a half weeks or so
the admissions to hospital and the
admissions to intensive care units of
hospitals
and the debts have not been rising and
in that sense
so far at least this second wave in
ireland at least and i think we see this
in other countries as well
is much less serious by those measures
than the first wave was so the question
i suppose that policy makers and medics
will have to answer
over the coming weeks is whether this
second wave
is permanently and qualitatively
different to the first wave
or whether the hospital admissions the
icu admissions and the debts
will catch up over the coming weeks and
that was one of the things
i think that fed into the government's
decision early on this week
not to move to to another lockdown was
that they felt they had the latitude
over the coming weeks
to wait and see if those indicators
catch up with the number of cases
so pat where does this leave now the
scientists and the politicians i mean
you wrote
the relationship between the government
and the scientific advisors
has been fundamentally reset i saw the
irish examiner saying that mr varadkar
the deputy t-shock didn't just throw dr
houlihan the chief medical officer under
the bus
he reversed the bus over him again and
again
so what quantum relations like that's a
reference to
an interview that mr veracle gave on
television on monday night in which
yeah as the examiner said it he pretty
much did drive the bus over
uh uh over tony houlihan now the two men
have since
had a conversation and they say that
they are looking forward to working
together etc etc over uh
over the coming weeks but what has
changed
very clearly between the public health
experts on one side of the government on
the other is that
early on in this pandemic during the
first wave the then government
basically made a virtue of saying we are
not going to make the decisions here
the doctors are going to make the
decisions we will at all
times take the public health doctor's
advice and that's what gave ireland
it's pretty quick pretty draconian
fairly extensive and ultimately quite
successful lockdown
in in terms of how it suppressed the
virus uh before the summer
but at this stage in this second wave i
think what the government is saying
given the economic damage that has been
done
and the sort of pressure that the social
fabric both collectively and
individually has been
under in many cases they've taken the
view that
while deaths and icu admissions remain
under control
they have got to take a whole heap of
other factors
into consideration when they're making
their decisions and like it or not that
means that the
public health advice is only the
scientific advice
is only one factor that they consider
rather than the only factor that they
consider so in that respect
the relationship has changed profoundly
i think the final question on this
before we
move on but i hope you stay with us
because i'm sure people have questions
to ask
because the irish experience is
fascinating to to follow
i assume that the prime minister the t
shock uh has got complete
coalition ireland has always been
governed
but is being governed by a coalition
that he's
he's got the coalition around him
in support of this because if it turned
out to be wrong
and the government actually had to move
to
tougher lockdown steps that would
probably be a political crisis for the
government
yeah i attended the press conference
late in government buildings on monday
night when this uh
after this decision was enhanced and the
health minister
you know when asked this question said
look you know it's not about who's right
and who's wrong here
well you know i think it might actually
turn out to be it's exactly
i was going to say it sounds to me like
it is if the government is approved
over the coming weeks if you do get this
rapid advance
in hospital admissions and icu
admissions and subsequently deaths
and if the government in layman's terms
is seen to have been wrong
then i think you know it will come
under very severe political pressure
at present and we have an opinion poll
which should be published in the irish
times
uh later this evening which shows that
public backing for the government
remains pretty strong and
i i think if it seemed to have got this
wrong
by the progress of the virus over the
coming weeks
uh then i think just as the politics
will turn on them
i think public opinion will turn on them
and
uh and clearly that could be very
serious for them
well thank you for that pat uh professor
david nabarro
is just joining us from the world health
organization i'm going to go to them in
a minute but i want to go to katie first
you've been listening to that i would
think that a lot of
tory backbenchers and even tory
ministers watching this and we know they
do
uh watch spectator tv i suspect a lot of
them will be saying
well i wish our government would stand
up to some of these scientific advices
would i be right can't you i think you
would be right i think we've seen
sweden uh that you hear often hear tory
mp
saying well look there is another way we
see that with the swedish approach so
i think the fact that a government even
closer to us is saying
you know we are thinking about going a
different path perhaps not the you know
the conventional wisdom
is something that is going to be picked
up and just put pressure on number 10
again
and it definitely i think you have to
bear in mind chris whitty and patrick
valance
they are not particularly popular in the
tory back benches
and there's a running joke that in a way
they they're holding boris johnson
hostage
in fact i think one of the best things
that's happened to dominic cummings is
chris whitty and patrick valance because
they at least get half the back bench
anger at the moment so
i think the fact that you have
government saying well we need to
balance more factors
with pressure and boris jones to not
just take his advisors
scientific advisors words for gospel and
something which
again very more popular than borah
johnson right now rishi sunak is seen as
doing weighing up lots of different
options
so i think this will add to the
arguments that have been put
against the current number 10 strategy
all right katie thanks for that
we're joined now by professor david
nabarro he is a special envoy
to the world health organization on
covert he reports
directly to the director general
professor
welcome to spectator tv up
36.5 million cases
of covert across the globe over a
million
fatalities are we past the worst or not
can we
can we see an end to this yet or not
thank you very much andrew and i'd like
to greet you and greet everybody
sorry for being a bit late to go
straight to the question
uh no we're not past the worst of it
i've
my own view is this virus is actually
towards the beginning of its
relationship with the human race
our estimates suggest that possibly as
many as 10 percent of the human
population so far have been exposed to
it
there's still 90 of the human population
an awful lot of people
who are susceptible to it so we're
saying
that uh we we really do have to learn
how to coexist
with this virus in a way that doesn't
require
constant closing down of economies
but at the same time in a way that
is not associated with high levels of
suffering and death it's what we're
calling the middle path
and the middle path uh is about being
able to hold
the virus at bay whilst keeping
economic and social life going and we
think it's doable
but we also think that it requires a
really high
level of organization by governments and
remarkable degree of uh engagement by
the people both of which
in some countries is proving to be quite
difficult indeed i want to come on to
that now i'm fascinated by the
how you describe it uh as the middle way
and who's doing it right and
and and who should take more interest in
the
middleware professor but let me ask you
this because you take a global view of
these things
am i right in saying that at the end of
the day
we didn't really have a proper global
response to this that
that individual countries in the end
they went their own way
would that be unfair or is that accurate
no it's totally right
actually it's explicable firstly this is
a brand new virus
and it it's absolutely not like any
other virus
that those of us who've been involved in
infectious diseases
have encountered before even the sars
virus of 2003
was different from this one and and
because it's new we're learning about it
all the time
so it's not surprising that quite a lot
of government
said well the wh sho is having to learn
about it
and they don't really know so we'll go
our own way as well
and we've already heard even on this
program that
there are quite wide variations my own
view is the debt short-sighted
if you're dealing with a common enemy
and this virus doesn't change whether
it's in
britain or in bahrain it's still the
same virus we should surely be working
on it together
but the reality is it's been a
remarkably
uncoordinated and disjointed response
tell me more about this middleware you
were talking about because
as we look back we can see when the
pandemic began to gather speed
uh most major economies went for a
lockdown
and and people accepted that but there
was a real fear of the unknown we don't
know much about this
this seems to be the the right way for
we better do that
and then we you know by we i don't just
mean britain i mean france spain even
america and
other countries too outside the western
hemisphere
they began to pull back a bit from
lockdown
and it seemed to be that we were getting
a little bit back to normality and then
the cases started to rise and the
instinct of governments was then to
move back not necessarily to national
lockdowns but to a variety of different
kind of
of lockdowns people are now beginning to
think if this
is the right response that that
we know more about this virus now than
we did before we know
it's rarely fatal for young people but
it is
often fatal for those who are over 70s
and maybe what we've learned now ought
to inform our policy
yeah not the middle way well it it's
almost i'm
i'm not going to go on long long because
you'll cut me anyway but
here it goes the middle way is really
trying to make certain that we put in
place
robust defenses against this virus so
that if it does start to build up
anywhere
we can catch it quickly and we can
suppress
outbreaks fast to do that
we need really two things one is very
well organized
localized uh infectious disease control
services sometimes they're called public
health services
it's not hospitals but it is testing
contact tracing and isolation the
backbone to controlling this kind of
thing
is always testing contact tracing and
isolation
the second part of it is involving local
actors
as much as possible because trying to do
dealing with small
spikes of disease is best done locally
it's not best done from some central
control center
and thirdly it works best if people
as on side as they possibly can be it
does mean
really leveling with people saying
actually the only way we can do this is
all of us pulling together physical
distancing
face protection hygiene isolating if
we're ill
not going off to work or to the pub if
we're feeling rotten
and protecting those who are most at
risk if we can combine those various
steps
what we call doing it all you know in
our organization speak
then we can get on top of it that's what
east asian countries have done
indeed what germany is doing pretty well
uh uh uh took a good effect that's what
parts of canada are doing
and that's the approach that we believe
should be adopted we think
lockdowns only serve one purpose and
that is
to give you a bit of breathing space so
you
just stop everything the virus stops
moving and while you've got that
breathing space you should be
really building up your testing building
up your contact tracing
building up your local organization so
that as you release lockdown you're
bound to get more cases
but you can deal with it really really
elegantly at the moment
western europe's not quite there but it
could get there and
i actually have a lot of hope for
ireland i've done a lot with uh dr
houlihan
and his team and i think there's a
they've got a good chance actually
of being able to do it uh hopefully
without having to do another lockdown
but just localized movement restrictions
but what did what did you make of the
irish politician the irish government
saying
to its scientific advisers no we're not
going to do that
it's right that there should be
interplay
between the public health doctors and
government in the end government has to
take responsibility
for balancing what might be seen as
the trade-off between health and the
economy
our line is to say let that be temporary
what we want you to do because this
virus is going to be around for quite a
long time to come
is work out how you can keep the economy
going
and keep the numbers of disease cases
down
and i suspect that's what's going to
happen as a result of this latest
uh wobble they'll find an accommodation
and
county by county allen will get on top
of this virus it's
it's happening i think already from what
i'm picking up from colleagues
the only thing to watch out for is that
sense among the public that they're
being pulled around too much
yes and they don't do what they're asked
to do
yes and then the rules have seemed to
have got more i mean in the early days
lockdown rules were pretty you may not
have liked them but they were quite
simple to follow
then now you kind of you take a notebook
around with you when the prime minister
doesn't even know
what they are then maybe the rest of us
don't necessarily know what they are
but you know sorry professor and you go
andrew just one thing you know this is
so new
this terrible virus it's not nice it's a
horrible it's it's dangerous
and it's uh cunning this virus is so new
to humanity
we're only uh nine months into it really
if you
if you think of how long it's been in
europe i think it'll take us
uh quite a lot more weeks to really work
out how we're going to live with this
virus what balance of risk we're
prepared to tolerate
and also how we will collectively
organize ourselves
but i reckon that early next year we'll
be feeling much more comfortable and it
will become second nature but right now
it's a bit stumbling in the dark we
we sometimes bulk at the lockdown
because it's yet another lockdown we
thought
we'd all be over there by this by
september uh october
it also as i said it gets very
complicated and so on but these are
quite
narrow personal inconveniences and and
of course they can have economic impacts
uh overall too but we had professor
sunetra
uh gupta from oxford university on and
she was implying and i mentioned you
because you have a global mandate a
global view
but the a problem we don't think about
in lockdowns is that they're very
nationalistic
that if we lock down our economy then it
hits our economy
but it also means we are not buying
stuff we're not trading with weaker
economies we are
not just destroying our own jobs we're
destroying the jobs of all those that
in the poorer parts of the world that
export to us that
seemed to me to be a reasonable point
really important point by professor
gupta i want to say it again
we in the world health organization do
not
advocate lockdowns as a primary means of
control of this virus
the only time we believe a lockdown is
justified
is to buy you time to reorganize regroup
rebalance your resources protect your
health workers who are exhausted
but by and large we'd rather not do it
just look what's happened to the tourism
industry for example in the caribbean
or in the pacific because people aren't
taking the holidays
looks what's happened to smallholder
farmers all over the world
because their markets have got dented
look what's happening to poverty levels
it seems that we may well have a
doubling of world poverty
by next year we may well have at least a
doubling of child malnutrition because
children are not getting
meals at school and their parents in
poor families
are not able to afford it this is a
terrible ghastly global
catastrophe actually and so we really do
appeal to all world leaders
stop using lockdown as your primary
control method
develop better systems for doing it work
together
and learn from each other but remember
lockdowns just have
one consequence that you must never ever
uh belittle
and that is making poor people an awful
lot poorer
indeed and horizon world poverty after
years and years in which world poverty
was falling and falling and
we've reversed almost decades of
progress gone back in
nine months professor thank you for
being uh with us don't go away because
i'm sure
a lot of people want to ask some
questions i'm going to move back to dear
old blighty where i'm afraid
lockdowns are still the policy du jour
and across the united kingdom
new covert restrictions are sweeping
over the land scottish pubs and
restaurants uh
uh face closure or a 6 p.m curfew uh
rumors abound in westminster the north
of england will be
quick to follow maybe on monday our
political editor james forsythe points
out in this week's
spectator cover story that is not a
national lockdown
but there are differences now between
the devolved nations between the north
and the south of england and all of that
is politically
perilous for a westminster government uh
we're going to come to that shortly
but do local lockdowns even work let's
go to
kate andrews she's got the data kate hi
andrew
thanks for that uh fascinating to hear
david navarro speak about the impact of
lockdown in the round and
now we can look at the data in the round
as well so i'm just going to
share my screen and it's been a while
since we've had sir patrick valance's
graph that he uh put forward a few weeks
ago
presented by government anyway here at
the spectator we're following it
closely i'm sure our watchers will
remember both when they gave this press
conference and the spectator's follow-up
of this graph that valence scenario
suggested that cases would be doubling
every seven days and get to
roughly 50 000 cases per day by
mid-october
they didn't include france or spain
as possible scenarios which was odd at
the time and still odd now as we had
been told for weeks and months that we
were following a similar
trajectory we've updated that trajectory
here
and we've also updated where we're
actually at in terms of the uk
seven day rolling average which is here
close to thirteen thousand cases in the
seven day rolling average today's new
update of daily cases is 17
500 just over in fact chris witty the
chief medical officer suggests that this
could be
tied to under 30s going to restaurants
and pubs
will come to that and but i think what
you can see here is still that the news
is not fantastic the uk looks well ahead
of france and spain in this trajectory
so
it's not as if this is a non-issue but
we're still
thousands and thousands of cases off
where uh patrick valens
suggested he said it wasn't a prediction
but only presented one scenario
suggested we could be and
certainly important to keep that
scenario held to account given it was
the only one that we were actually
presented with
um so the government's brought in
significantly more local lockdown
measures um in
in the north and in midlands over the
past few months as you mentioned andrew
in scotland nicola sturgeon has brought
in
perhaps some of the strictest local
lockdown measures to date
it will actually shut down pubs and
restaurants for everything but takeaways
for 16 days
and the times reports that it looks like
similar measures may be coming to
areas of the north as well so what
impact if any have these local lockdowns
actually
had and this is absolutely fascinating
this represents almost
50 councils and you can see here that
that black line in the middle
is is where these local councils would
have been put under local lockdown
and what happened to their infection
rates after they were
and in the vast majority of cases they
skyrocketed compared to where
they were before it does not seem as if
these local measures
have had any meaningful impact on
infection the only one you can really
point to
is lester it did go down for a bit
infections have risen
again although nowhere near as they have
in other areas but of course lester's
is still in a local lockdown and this
raises many questions as
in terms of what these measures are
actually doing but the one that
comes to mind for me is it's very clear
from this chart that
lester was getting better that
infections were decreasing
and yet it wasn't ever taken out of
local lockdown formally and it still has
more restrictions than other parts of
the uk and
other parts of england i should say and
and one does have to
wonder why we still don't know what the
criteria is actually to be put
into local lockdown or to be taken out
of it and i'm sure james will speak to
that
as he's penned an excellent cover piece
on the topic uh but the last chart i'm
going to show you is
where these infections are happening and
this is taken from public health
england's weekly coven 19 surveillance
report and
i think this is interesting because a
lot of the local lockdown measures
especially those
proposed in scotland now coming to
england as well
focus on hospitality is it's the
shutdown of pubs
and restaurants but as you can see here
andrew so far
it's thought that outside of household
mixing
out in in public venues food outlets and
restaurants are accounting for
four percent of where incidents are
confirmed for outbreaks of two or more
cases the workplace education settings
and care homes are significantly higher
now that doesn't necessarily mean we
should go and shut down these other
sectors education is a very good example
we know that children are just
a lot less likely to have a severe
impact uh severe conditions from this
virus so there are many factors to take
into account
but the fact that hospitality is being
so heavily targeted when it's accounting
for such a small percentage of these
cases so far
is going to raise a lot of eyebrows
especially for
politicians in these local areas who are
hearing from
small businesses the owners of pubs the
owners of these restaurants who
just about got through the first
lockdown are on their knees desperate to
get customers back in the door
and may well be hearing in the coming
days weeks and months that they actually
have to shut again
uh so on that note andrew i'll stop
sharing my screen and hand it back over
to you
all right thank you uh for that kid my
main takeaway
there is that infamous uh witty balance
uh
projection not prediction but projection
as you rightly say the only one
that they gave us we're we're
now in october the eighth they projected
until the middle of the month about the
15th i think of
the 13th we're nowhere near that but we
are worse at the same stage
than francis spain that is interesting
it is interesting and it raises an
important point if you don't level with
the public and make clear what the
actual problems are and
and lay out several different kinds of
scenarios ones that are perhaps not the
worst case but more likely as to where
you're going to end up then
the public can look at that data reflect
on that data and perhaps
change their behavior accordingly but i
think when you set out one scenario
especially one that
is clearly designed to frighten people
they might not believe it
in future and as you can see from the
graph that i showed andrew the uk is not
in a great place
when it comes to infections especially
compared to france and spain but the
problem is they set out the worst case
scenario so a lot of people are saying
well
we don't just don't quite believe it i
see david nabarro waving at me there i
think
david come on in super quick
you see i would really
rather that instead of moving straight
to
local lockdowns that it was instead
local integrated responses because
the way actually we help to get on top
of these outbreaks whether they're in
care homes
or in education or in hospitals or in
factories and prisons
is we do it by involving all the
different local actors together
it may be involving religious uh
institutions churches synagogues not
involving factories maybe involving
uh of course the local health officers
it really may be involving
a community organization but bring them
together and you know i i
of the various places that you were
highlighting i know a bit about
leicester
and what i've really enjoyed watching
the leicester
response is the quality of the
local integration that has gone on in
that city
during the last few weeks and the way in
which
it's meant really getting close to
and involved with the different
communities where there has been the
virus spreading
and and we think from looking around the
world
that's what really makes a difference is
when you get everybody coming together
and saying we're going to work on this
with the local actors and we're going to
connect with them
if necessary using different languages
or using different idioms
but that seems to be the real way uh to
to reduce the risk of these things
building up i'm sorry to interrupt
no not at all feel free that's what we
like there's a bit of a dialogue here
and
and people to say what they think and
we're going to stick
local because i'm delighted now to be
joined by the mayor for middlesbrough in
north yorkshire andy preston in
middlesbrough households they're no
longer allowed to mix indoors or
outdoors and
stricter restrictions may be coming in
uh mayor preston last week made a
defined uh
videos that went a little bit viral
which he said you would
he would defy the government's
restrictions
uh mayor president what what is it that
is upsetting you about current
government policy as it affects
middlesbrough oh do we have the mayor of
middlesbrough
no let's see if we can get him back i'll
go to him in a minute
we've got james forsyth who's done a
cover story on this we'll try and get
the mayor back you know lines to
middlesbrough often go down these days
you know
uh let me come to james forsythe because
james you've done the cover sir
it seems to me there's a danger that the
government's going to get itself into a
bit of a mess with all this
uh different kind of response in
different parts of the country james
yeah i think there is a huge risk
because
the tory majority was based on
persuading voters in those red wall
seats in the north
but these weren't the same old tourists
that they genuinely
cared about these northern areas and i
think the problem is this
you've already got andy burnham and
other local leaders in the north
complaining about a lack of consultation
from government and as
k andrew said if the government doesn't
have clear
criteria for when an area goes into
enhanced restrictions and
what comes out of them even if the
process isn't political
it's going to look political uh one
calendar
said to me this week it's going to be
like flooding people will say look it
would happen different that everything
would be different if this was in surrey
ra was happening in surrey the support
would be more generous the problem would
be dealt with quicker
now i mean the truth is the government
is struggling to deal with this virus
all across england but i think the
problem is
in march it was quite easy to create a
spirit of national solidarity
because this was a new and scary virus
and everyone was in the same boat indeed
if you think back to march one of the
reasons why the idea of a london only
lockdown was rejected even though the
virus
was much more prevalent in london
anywhere else in the country was that
ministers did this would send out a
message that lives in london were
regarded as somehow more valuable
than in the rest of the country the
government is now in the kind of
opposite way around which is
you know life and the economy in the
south is going to continue
in something close to normal yes
there'll be a 10 p.m
but you won't have the kind of closures
that we're looking at in
liverpool manchester and newcastle and
that's a particular problem because that
means that when the economic support
package is announced
there will be lots of people saying oh
well i think this would be more generous
if it this was affecting
you know the torah the old tory
heartlands in the southeast the eastern
under all of the south western world
and i think this is one of the reasons
why even though the country is better
prepared in terms of medical knowledge
uh and hospital beds and the like for
the for this second wave and it was the
first wave
the second wave is going to be much
harder politically for the government
right i think we've made contact with
the mayor of middlesbrough again
uh andy preston welcome to spectator tv
you know so much of this coverage comes
out of the westminster bubble
uh but here you are on spectator tv the
mayor of middlesbrough
how does it look from where you sit and
how does the government's response look
um so what it looks from where we sit is
there is a situation where people are
non-plussed i mean as
as i think everybody said earlier this
this
this thing was predicted to have caused
mayhem and killed lots of people and
what most people know is that
statistically the virus is spreading but
most people don't yet
know anybody who's died i think we have
to take it incredibly
nobody knows what's ahead of us by the
way with infections hospitalizations
and mortality but absolutely uh
professor namara's spot on
we need to find a way of working with
this and what what happened
last week was westminster the government
said to middlesbrough and other places
we are going to do something to you
we're not going to work with you we're
not going to listen to local knowledge
we're not going to look at local data
we're going to do something to you we're
going to effectively
close down your your food and beverage
business plunging
thousands of people into unemployment
and the corresponding
economic impact the physical health that
meant if i may say
uh as a 54 year old who grew up in the
in the 80s left school 82
the industrial recession then was
terrifying
and and middlesbrough council our tiny
university authority is still paying
probably about 15 million quid a year
in child care in social health in all
kinds of ways
paying for the way that that industrial
recession was handled 35 years ago so
we've spent
hundreds of millions and what we need to
do now is as other people have said is
look at this problem as a
not just a covert numbers problem but a
physical health a mental health and a
long-term economic shock
and i fear i fear that what we're
looking at is how do we get the numbers
down get the numbers down get the
numbers down
and to use the whack-a-mole analogy i
fear boris johnson is
whacking the same mole when the others
are popping up
so i think this is there's a sense that
we are a victim
again there's a sense we aren't being
consulted or listened to and there's a
sense that the government is
doing stuff to us without giving us a
chance
to explain why they might be able to do
it better
so your heart must sink then at the
prospect of more lockdown measures
coming in because that's all the buzz
out of the government
it's just they can't quite it seems
can't quite make up their mind
exactly what they should be it's become
incredibly complicated
they're saying it may not come into
monday we're already on a thursday
now it would seem that the government is
set on a course off which you don't
approve
is that fair yes that is absolutely
right um i mean all the data we have
does say that the vast majority
something like 82
of cases locally are derived from inside
the home socializing at home so we need
to
we actually ask for a temporary
restriction on socializing at home
but why shouldn't somebody be allowed to
stand on their garden path and talk with
a neighbor
why shouldn't i be able to take my wife
for
dinner in a really well known restaurant
the
the risks of contracting a virus there
in a well-run establishment are
are literally minuscule and to plunge so
many people into unemployment to cause
so much mental health problems
and and store up this potential 35-year
time bomb as we had from the 80s
recession seems
bizarre at best negligent at worst and
we need to be looking at this
pragmatically i think professor nabarro
admitted that we don't know much about
this i'm not soft on kobe by the way
i've introduced all kinds of measures
to try and deal with it but we're
learning as we go we need to try
different things and see what works
but but local is good we need central
government
and local government to work together
and that's the bit andrew that's missing
the northern mayors um which have not
been a par in the land since victorian
times but you are
a power in the land now and you all
labour and conservative or independent
you seem to be speaking with broadly
one voice on these things there may be
details you differ about
but as i've seen from andy burnham and
manchester for example and others
there's a broadly the same analysis and
the same criticism
coming out hasn't that cut any ice with
the government if you've got these
mayors
across political parties representing
our great northern cities
hasn't that made the government think
what it looks like to me as an outsider
i'm not an insider into westminster it
looks like there's a key
group a small group that is advising has
got the era of the pm
and maybe a few others and and that is
dictating how the pm
sees and feels things um and that's
rippling out across the country
um it's it's crazy and
and we don't want people to do exactly
what we want
but we want people to listen to what we
want and tell us why they can't do it
that that's that's all we want
we're not listening they're not
listening they're not listening at all
no there hasn't been a single
despite what you hear otherwise the
truth is there has not been
one conversation with the senior member
of government or a senior civil servant
uh with anybody in middlesbrough or
hartlepool in the last
few weeks yet the terrorists are
supposed to be the party of the north
now
well i believe that there's a real will
there from the tories to level up i do
believe it as an independent i i i think
that they want to do great
things but this is this is this
is so difficult it's a crisis governing
in a crisis is a nightmare
at the beginning in any crisis what
happens is everyone rallies around you
and that's what happened in the spring
loads of popularity
it's now getting frayed this is classic
crisis uh uh behavior
and the government's own people are
turning on and this this could go
very very badly wrong for the government
and the country
and i think the the easy way to fix it
is start talking
start listening to a broader range of
people and start communicating
very interesting mr mayor thank you for
joining us don't go away we're going to
get some questions before we do
we'll take a quick segue across the
atlantic that was the uh
vice presidential debate last night
between uh senator
kamala harris and vice president mike
pence it's the only vice presidential
debate
so far normally they don't matter very
much but for reasons uh
to do with the uh age of the two
candidates who are leading the
democratic republic tickets uh suddenly
who the vice president might be has
become of much more important
very freddie gray did without sleep
watched it happening and make sure that
uh we knew what was happening ourselves
he's editor
of the spectators american edition he
joins me now freddie
it was a proper debate unlike uh mr
trump and mr biden this was a good
old-fashioned debate with even the odd
facts thrown in
there was even the odd facts and uh even
a little bit of policy discussed
um at the same time i'm not sure we
learned that much
about uh differing visions between the
two parties about the future of america
what we did learn is is a little bit
about the two candidates and i'd say
that
the overwhelming impression i had is
that mike pence who is
still favorite to be the next leader of
the republican party the next
nominee at the next major election
uh it was it's actually a very
accomplished uh performer i see the
polls are sort of split some people say
cameron harris won
and i don't think she did badly but i
think overall uh
pence was engaged um intelligent and he
spoke very fluently and when you compare
it to
trump's performance last week i i think
um
he's not i've never been a particular
fan of him i think he's always been
quite dull
but he is actually a an intelligent
speaker
uh we've i i agree with you i
i thought uh vice president pence he was
more articulate and across the subject
than i expected them to be i expected
kamala harris
to be across it she's very smart and
savvy
and and you know is a policy wonk in
some ways too
but it's now been slightly overshadowed
by this announcement of the president
today
uh that the debates commission has
announced the next presidential debate
will be virtual and mr trump has said
i'm not doing that is that wise given
that he is the one
that's coming from behind well i think
the president has been reading
uh spectators american website because
um
his uh his old advisor published a
slightly
uh eccentric let's say advisor published
a rather wild piece saying he didn't
think
uh trump should do the debate and it's
sort of quite a controversial thing for
roger stone to say he's obviously quite
a controversial
figure um but it seems to me that uh
trump has decided that if if it's going
to be a virtual debate
he's not willing to do it and he's going
to try and boss the situation
and say he wants to change the debate to
move it back so that it can be a
physical
debate the the biden campaign is adamant
that that shouldn't be the case and they
they say why should
the president get to to say when the
debate should be
uh and so it looks to me as though the
second debate may not happen which
actually suits
the biden campaign fine because the sort
of atmosphere you got from the democrats
last week was
few uh we got away with it um biden
didn't have a terrible moment
um and so all the debates are now with
his huge pole lead or growing pole lead
or a banana skin and so if they can
avoid one then they will
well that's why i don't quite understand
what mr trump's taking this
position and it's not entirely
unprecedented to do an effective virtual
debate
there were three debates between mr
nixon and mr kennedy in 1960
in one of them it was either the second
or the third
mr nixon was in los angeles in an abc
studio
and mr kennedy was in new york well
that's the equivalent
of a virtual debate isn't it they did it
well i'm not sure anyone quite
understands what donald trump thinks
at any time but particularly uh at the
moment he seems to be going
full gonzo uh i mean his fans like to
say that he
he's sort of playing four-dimensional
chess and we sort of figured it we
figure out how brilliant it is
a few months later i think if he is
doing it if he is doing something like
that it's sort of six or seven
dimensional chess and we just don't know
what he's playing at i think his whole
reaction to having covid uh it may be
because of the drugs he's been given
oh he's pumped up on steroids one of his
advisors
i want to get some myself after having
stayed up for that debate
all right well it's fascinating to to
see but
i mean i would have thought the
president needs another debate but more
than the
uh challenger mr biden uh anyway let's
go to some questions
this is one i think this is clearly for
professor nabarro
it's a good question from steven uh sad
he says why has asia done so much better
than europe thailand singapore taiwan
uh is it because they closed the border
sooner
it wasn't just that it was a professor
they had experience from
sars and test and trace they were they
were more ready to move in that
direction is that right
they moved without hesitation stephen
and andrew they were amazing uh
we we actually watched what was going on
in february
and we noticed four things from all
these asian countries
firstly they got their public on side
but not entirely through top down
pressure even though that's how it's
been
sometimes reported but it was a true
sense among the public
that we got to pull together on this one
with distancing and masking secondly
they really developed their public
health capacity like a honeycomb across
the community
so they knew where people were ill they
knew where they had to put their tests
and they got their tests out really
quickly
into the local communities number three
they worked out that their hospitals had
to keep going
not just for cobit but for other
illnesses and that was super important
and the fourth thing
is the governments did not muck around
they went into
covid readiness super fast and it was
all because they'd had
sars before that disease that came along
in 2003
and i think there is an element quite
honestly
of people just getting on and doing what
needs to be done without mucking around
and just last point on this that i've
learned since this all started
that if you're quick and robust and
deal with the problem just when there
are a few cases
and yes you have to do some fairly
intense stuff but it's still
quick and and right at the beginning
it's
much much much easier to get on top of
it than if you delay for two or three
weeks wondering what to do
because this virus just multiplies like
anything particularly when it's just
starting
and then cleaning up if you waited three
weeks is so much tougher
and that's why we see some of the
countries that have been a bit slow
or half-hearted in dealing with it have
got a much nastier problem now
than for example the ones that were
quick and robust
indeed i mean i was looking at the
figures for taiwan
uh they've had one new case of this week
a population of 22 million they've had
seven deaths during the whole businesses
and only 524
cases is like remarkable there let me
move on professor because i've got a
question here
from roland g for mayor preston of
middlesbrough
he says don't the city mayors need to
have one
united voice now to be a single voice to
get together
nominate a single voice on this
particular issue obviously you
disagree about hosts of other things and
that way your
voice would matter more to central
government
mr mayor um clearly if everyone agrees
then a single voice is
is is very good i'm not certain everyone
does disagree but i saw
andy burnham's comments today and i i
think he's spot on i mean i would say
that because he agrees with me but
but but i do think he's spot on uh annie
burnham is uh
as we know he's a labour man through and
through but he's a level-headed
uh popular and and widely acknowledged
um
reasonable man so andy burnham would be
a phenomenal spokesman for me and i
would back him if he wants to go to
government we do need to unite
it isn't an uprising of the north it
isn't about bringing a government down
it's just saying
let's work on this together let's use
local skills
expertise and knowledge to sort our
problems out
we'll all benefit katie uh
balls a question for you from alex
bircher
what wants to know if the tory rebels
plan to vote down this 10 p.m
curfew for pubs and residents and we
know it's very unpopular
has it been kibosh because labour's
decided
not to vote alongside the rebels katie
yes there are lots of tory rebels who
would love to vote down in this 10 p.m
curfew i think some of them are in
cabinet that they
probably wouldn't actually go ahead with
the rebellion
more talk about on the sidelines but
it's unlikely to happen because
there was a moment when these rebels
thought this week they might have the
numbers because
at prime minister's questions kistama as
you touched on
asked boris johnson for the evidence of
for the curfew knowing full well
there's not too much in the way of
scientific evidence however the labour
leader has since
signaled that he's not going to oppose
it so unless that changes it looks very
hard for the numbers to be there
but i do think we are seeing a slight
shift in tone from kirsten how he
uh provides opposition to coronavirus
restrictions
so there could be chances for the rebels
to come in the coming weeks
and to potentially work with labour
james
the tory view at the moment
don't they think things are a bit grim
from a tory point of view
yes undoubtedly um as one
parliamentarian who's
very close to boris johnson's but it's
mean fundamentally the tory party is in
a very unhappy place because half a
party
really dislikes these restrictions and
the dominance of the scientists i think
number 10's hope that someone someone
there said to me this week is look
you know the logic of the numbers they
think is undeniable and they
think that this rapid rise in cases
will persuade people that boris johnson
has to do what he's doing in terms of
these lockdowns
uh local lockdowns i mean the problem is
this
the problem is a the problem that annie
talked about communication
there's a sense there's sort of slightly
arbitrary the way this is working
and also a frustration that 12 billion
pounds has been spent on this test and
trace system
12 billion yes more than a thousand
consultants working on it from one
management consultancy alone
and yet test and trace seems to be
really struggling
to get on top of the virus you know it's
struggling to trace people's close
contacts
and i think there is a feeling that you
know everyone was told as we came out of
the first wave
that you know the way we were going to
avoid lockdowns the second time round
was that test and trace was going to get
on top of it test and trace is
clearly not doing that and this isn't a
kind of
uh this isn't a system on the cheap this
is a 12
billion pound system that is more than
two aircraft carriers
that's serious money and i mean there's
real irritation but test and trace is
not delivering
insane uh uh andrews that's i
it to begin with politicians talked
about we're following the science
but as the weeks and the months have
gone on it's become clear that there
isn't
the science there are varying sciences
there are various
opinions and why would you not expect
that it's a as professor nabarro
was saying it's a new thing we're
learning about it all the time
but it's quite clear now that science is
quite divided on this i've seen this
this
what has rather granted being called the
great barrington declaration after a
town
in new england but it does involve
leading professors from oxford harvard
stanford
it doesn't get better than that they are
against
the the the knee-jerk reaction to go
into further lockdown there's a real
debate taking place and
in the scientific community and i would
suggest it puts the politicians in a
difficult position
because what side do they come down and
who do they follow in the science now
well it reminds us that these are
political decisions at the end of the
day you can take advice from anywhere
you
want but at some point the leader has to
make a decision and i can imagine a
world where the prime minister number 10
might be listening to
different scientists some that we've
even had on this program andrew
if our excess death rate in the first
round of covet 19 weren't so high
england had the highest number of excess
deaths in europe
the uk has had the largest economic
contraction of any major country the
first leg of the race so to speak
has not gone well and let's not forget
that the prime minister twice this week
put on record on
national television that he thinks there
will be a game changer
in the next six months he told the mar
program that by next march there'd be
this game changer at party conference he
said
by next september there won't be
restrictions there won't be socially
distance
there won't be social distancing so he
thinks something's gonna give
and if you do really hold that belief
then you don't mind being strict for
another six months and perhaps you do
throw a lot more money at the situation
to be able to do so
because you think something's going to
change the problem of course is a lot of
scientists out there think
that there may not be a vaccine around
the corner we may have to learn to live
with this virus for much longer
and in that situation when you get to
next march what on earth do you do
perhaps you have to change tack then but
it's much harder to do so when you've
hunkered down in these strict lockdown
roles for
a year well he sounds a bit like
chauncey gardner in being there remember
the peter salas
character who always said there will be
growth in the spring
and that was taken to be a great
meaningful insight by the president
in that movie but it turned out he just
meant that the flowers came back
in the spring but let me go back to
dublin for a final take from you
how long pat before
we'll know if the irish government took
the right decision or not
i think if you look at really it's a
matter
of weeks do you get that sort
of does the decoupling that has taken
place between
the rate of new infections and
hospital admissions icu admissions and
ultimately debts
does that continue or is this just
a a question of the debts and so forth
catching up with the um with the
infections and we know that i think
within a couple of weeks what the
government has said and i i mean i would
like to give the impression
earlier that there are no restrictions
here with the government of course
doing was going to a full lockdown there
are still
reasonably stringent uh restrictions the
pubs are closed
uh for uh for one thing so we feel
uh we feel your pain on that on that
regard but what the government is saying
is that it has to give these
medium uh strength restrictions
time to work so there's been a big push
now and there will be
over the coming weeks to get people to
actually observe
the uh the restrictions that are in at
the moment
big clampdown in recent days
by uh by the police uh on
on movement between parts of the country
and so forth and they think
that if they can get cooperation and
buy-in from
people because ultimately it's people's
behaviors in their daily lives that will
decide whether this thing spread and
then they can avoid going
to the full lockdown but really it'll be
i think
two three weeks or so before uh
whether they're successful well i hope
we can come back to you in two or three
weeks and see
for the city of players final question
trevor pittman
for professor nabarro what is the status
of the review
into the origins of the virus where are
we with that
i have just have to say that that is
ongoing it's a process
it's not something in which
unfortunately you can say
it will take a fixed amount of time to
find out these are really really
difficult reviews to do
you don't have lots and lots of things
to look at to give you answers so
i can only say that this is work
underway and i can't give you
a completion date but is who carrying
that out is that
a job for wh i i mean who will
do the organization but whatever you do
these kinds of things you
bring in other people you bring in
independent actors from
uh different organizations usually they
are uh
coming with a bit of a government
imprimatur on them
but you who would have to get other
staff to come in and help
i don't know the exact situation on
where that stands and i
i i can't give you more than this andrew
okay we'll leave it there that brings us
to an end thank you all
yes sorry i see you waving again
professor very briefly
i just want to say one very short thing
you know
ukraine russia poland
romania turkey hungary georgia have got
increasing death rates parts of france
uh intensive care filled up paris and
marseille
yeah and guadeloupe as well and also in
spain
you know we we could just be sitting on
a situation where in four weeks time
it all goes really bad again i just want
to ask everybody
not to assume that somehow england
ireland are going to have
a different experience from what we're
seeing in some other european
locations i think it's certainly clear
to all of us professor it certainly
isn't over
that's for sure thanks to you all
middlesbrough
dublin london france the world health
organization
we really are a global television
broadcaster
these days thanks to our guests thanks
all of you watching for joining the week
in 60 minutes
we'd love to find out what you thought
of it how we could improve
send your thoughts to spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
if you like this remember to subscribe
to our youtube
channel the spectators youtube channel
it's a surefire way
not to miss any future episodes you just
click the spectator
tv logo in the bottom right of the
screen thanks to our guest once again a
very special thanks to our sponsor
charles stanley
is one of the leading uk wealth
management firms
one of the oldest firms in the london
stock exchange they look after people's
money
we hope you're going to join us again
next thursday at 6 00 pm
uh london time for another the week in
60 minutes until then
bye bye
you